of course yesterday all this greatness
happens we have you know huge
celebrations in New York in the
California all over the place but our
Michelle Bachmann's and our Rick
Santorum's and our Mike Huckabee's we're
not as thrilled I got a great quote here
from Michele Bachmann she said yesterday
marriage was created by the hand of God
no man not even a Supreme Court justice
can undo what holy God has instituted
this coming from a woman who I'm pretty
sure has been in a gay marriage this
entire time
did you hear Nancy Pelosi they quoted
that entire quote Nancy Pelosi what do
you think she would who cares who cares
could you think of a less relevant
person than Michelle Bachman right now I
always think the people that are so
staunchly and openly homophobic are a
little gay well no they're totally gay
ok so there are people like that what do
we do with these people because Marcus
Bachmann is gay as a fruitcake and it's
like what what are we doing what are we
gonna do they're saying you're gonna
break up their marriage they got 18 kids
74 foster kids he's doing a conversion
camp take it please
they're the least intimidating people
out there I think I mean you look at
them they like will throw something out
there and then run away with their tail
between their legs if you look at Rand
Paul on the on Glenn Beck's show the
other day you know he did that very
obvious comparison to you know now that
we've made this gay marriage legal in
with DOMA you know the obvious analogy
about animals and very dog very quickly
we can everyone here confirm that you
don't can you confirm you will not marry
your dog your caddy or fish or your
lizard a 100% will not I mean I came
from a background that actually believed
that pedophilia fisty alley all those
things were the same thing
homosexuality like that was the
environment I grew up in and so when you
hear comparisons like that I think
you're making a good point Whitney which
is that people who are throwing the
stuff out there and then running away
those are the people we don't have to
actually feel uncomfortable around
because they make themselves look like
idiots and then look at everybody's
busted right now everybody's kind of
busted on their own ignorance I think
that's what DOMA did and what the
Supreme Court case did is like let's
really talk about this if you really
want to talk about this and talk about
the harm that it's gonna do and what's
gonna happen and when it came out that
no harm was gonna come to anybody you're
busted yeah so now all they can kind of
come up with is nonsense yeah and and
and Indiana the governor of Indiana is
saying that now he wants to put an anti
gay marriage initiative on the ballot
but now prop 8 has been struck down as
like we basically said in the highest
court that I'm voting on this is
unconstitutional right oh this is this
is a big wave and it's been unleashed
and you can't put it back in a little
cup Johnny even marrying your dog your
dog one final point on this what do you
guys do because you guys all live in the
digital space and we're doing this of
course from YouTube what do you do
forget the the Bachmann's and the
Santorum's and the rest of them what do
you guys do about just the online you
know these anonymous haters now we know
that the government is now watching them
so maybe I'll get a little nicer but
forgetting that what do you do when
you're dealing with with these people I
mean there's that slide over button and
delete like it's really that simple in
the in the technology age you can simply
ignore or black you know you don't have
to be privy to all that negativity out
there you can select what kind of
[ __ ] you want to hear really yeah
Bree do you have a policy on the haters
well I get a lot of hate a lot of the
time but the thing I like to do most is
just give them a little bit of love I
like to I know
well it's true
whatever they want I just like to be
like look like your life seems kind of
miserable I think you could use a little
bit of love so you may hate me but I
love you okay that was our kumbaya
moment Oh Alec you have apologized I
think here's the thing if you want to
post a nasty comment on YouTube or
Twitter or Facebook you're telling
everybody that that's who you are yeah
you're basically telling everybody that
this is who I am I'm a person who sits
in my house and writes nasty things
about people and and the thing is the
big challenge is is not to take it
personally when somebody says something
nasty and this is in life to it that has
more to do with them then it has to do
with you and you know my kids growing up
in the digital age he's already on the
iPad and the phone and everything and
he's gonna have a Facebook page
eventually and I have to teach him that
it's just words on a screen and it's up
to you how to interpret that you can
either take that personally and really
take it to art and let it hurt you or
you can go it's just words on a screen
yeah sure I think that you know the
Internet is a great resource in that it
provides anonymity which can be used for
good or for bad right so people can say
what they will about you and you just
what's really important is to kind of
set your own foundation within yourself
to be able to handle comments like
exactly especially when you make
yourself like a public figure I
fortunately have a super super awesome
community online and they're nine times
out of 10 very very positive and when
there is like a negative comment I got
the other day I posted a video about
marriage being like yeah I'm so happy
blah blah blah and this guy says you
know that's so like a lesbian she's the
epitome of lesbianism which I was like
really oh my god what is the epitome of
less I don't know cuz I actually dated
the best exactly um he said she's the
epitome of lesbianism cynical one other
negative thing and that I didn't want to
have babies and I was like we don't know
that
baby yeah I'll be dead are you kidding
me have you seen my hips like I am ready
for children yeah
Johnny what about you I'm sure now you
put up some pretty hyper sexualized
stuff online yeah and that is partly
what they seem to be afraid that were
all these like sex monsters we are I
believe me I wish I was having that much
sex you know but so you must get a
particular brand of that because you're
putting out stuff that and naked people
and put out a lot of videos that are
extremely forward in their game nature I
mean there's a lot of rap videos out
there with ladies dropping it like it's
hot and I'm an equal opportunity exploit
sir I feel it's very important because
if I was a young gay teen I'd love to be
able to watch booty videos of guys
dropping it like it's hot it's very
important yeah you're not a young gay
teen and you still like yeah and you can
continue to like that through your
entire what I would consider one of my
softest most gentle videos recently it's
a Gay Pride anthem called the gayest of
all time yep and still people were like
that is disgusting
how I'm like if you how can you look at
this video where the lesbians and gays
and trans and all get together and lips
like a song about being the gayest of
all time you think that's horrible and I
say that to myself and then I delete
block see you later ha well bye avenged
yeah those are always the funniest ones
when they they attack you for something
that you love about yourself like I see
sometimes feeling like oh well he likes
the Golden Girls I'm always like yeah
yeah what are we talking about you can't
please everybody
like we were at a at the frameline
festival just last weekend we did a
short film for kids with LGBT parents
and we posted it on boeing-boeing and
somebody said and this has features
every single ethnicity in it it's like
me my husband and my son we're like the
last two minutes if it's a small world I
mean it's like I'm Asian why'd he black
everything we got everything so somebody
posted Oh typical
they say they represent the entire
community but they they don't feature
any trans or bisexual stories meanwhile
our director and the writer of it and
creator is a bisexual trans woman so if
we're to say that 40% yeah I sexual
trans woman yeah is a person whose
transition she was m2f male to female
yeah transitioned and now she's living
is a female and she's bisexual and very
friendly and very talented filmmaking
yeah but it was like it's that it's kind
of you put things out there and you're
never gonna please everybody and I think
there also exists a community of people
that just live to kind of post negative